in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some fishing fashionistas
get a line on their cold boot
performance problems when we catch the
big one stay tuned to find out so last
episode I helped my friend Carter and
his new website bait and stitch which
allows fishermen to meet up with local
designers to create custom apparel we
were able to do a survey of the
different ways to profile app engine
startup time and realized a few things
firstly is that GAE standard startup
time is fast there's no issues with the
platform there secondly tracing was an
amazing tool to see where your time is
going to our PC or other system calls
and thirdly we could augment those
traces with custom data to get more info
on the performance of the code but we
didn't actually track down what the
problem was yet so to recap the logging
tools showed us that our loading
requests and a whole set of requests
afterwards are taking significantly
longer than the average which is about
three to seven milliseconds but upon
revisiting the logs I had a realization
check out those timestamps for those
slow requests they didn't come in after
the loading request but rather at the
same time as the loading request the
difference between the loading requests
and the ones following are roughly the
same millisecond given this fact the way
we should really be looking at this log
data is that there's two groups of
requests one that arrives at the same
time as the loading requests which are
slow and one that arrives afterwards
which are actually fast and with this
shift in thinking I suddenly realized
what was wrong parallel requests see if
you have thread-safe enabled in GAE
standard then your application can
receive parallel requests which will
spin off to separate threads to execute
work on the same instance this normally
is really important given that the fact
that it allows you to maximize your
usage of the instance that you have in
Carter's case however this is causing a
problem since something in the loading
request is causing the rest of the
parallel requests to block until it's
completed to confirm this you can look
at the logs in more detail you can see
that each parallel requests get
subsequently slower while it waits and
in some cases it's 2x slower than the
loading request itself but truth is that
this isn't normal behavior for parallel
requests after a bit more digging the
problem materialized pretty quickly
Carter was messing around with global
ver
labels and parallel requests turns out
that in the instance initialization for
baton stitch set some code that looked
like this when the instance booted for
the first time it would query NDB to get
some setting data that it keeps around
for use later now when you're writing
client-side applications work like this
really isn't a big deal since this type
of thing is typically done before your
thread pools are initialized but an app
engine initialization can happen in
parallel to your threading work the
result is that each one of these threads
will be trying to initialize the global
variables at the same time and since
they aren't thread local all the threads
will block and wait until the work is
finished this has a significant
performance impact since it turns your
parallel system into a single linear
operation the solution came from a very
simple realization not every one of our
requests actually used the global
variable but since the logic was
occurring globally all the threads and
requests were blocking on it the fix was
pretty easy at this point change the
global variable to be lazy initialized
based on the first instance that uses it
in this scenario Baden stitch still pays
the cost eventually to do the NDB query
but the trick here is that it's more
performant when the get CDN function is
not causing contention for other
parallel requests once we change this
code around we saw a significant
improvement in performance our loading
requests no longer block the rest of the
parallel requests and didn't create the
same blocking behavior now obviously
this is a specific case but you can see
how quickly cold boot time can cause
problems that impact your bottom line
for those folks who've worked in managed
languages and situations where startup
time matters most of this information is
old hat but in the world of cloud
computing these small performance
anomalies have serious consequences not
only for user perception of performance
but also in pure costs having 100
loading requests a day at a hundred and
eighty-seven X slower than regular
requests first result in significant
overhead and compute hours thankfully we
were able to peel back the layers of
complexity profile some new parts of the
code and save bait and stitch some
serious performance for their users if
that sounds pretty awesome to you then
make sure you check out the rest of the
cloud performance Atlas videos and don't
forget when it comes to performance
every mil
and counts